we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here's a caller who wants to know
are democrats abandoning the democratic
party because of woke
listen to this
hey david pachmann or park men uh first
time uh
caller uh wanting to uh ask you about
uh the left and uh wanted you to
speak on people kind of leaving the left
and turning away from the party because
it's becoming
a little bit too you know woke
um an example of maybe what bill maher
was saying where
you know
most
democrats classic democrats are staying
as the the party is moving along
appreciate it a big fan thanks david
pass or pachmann or passman
thanks
yeah very very much struggling with my
name so listen this is just a question
of party registration
if we look at the party registration
trend going back to 2004 which is 18
years
you see a similar percentage of the
country registered as democrats it
really hasn't moved very much right
after barack obama won in 2008 you saw a
little bit of a spike in the number of
americans who were registered as
democrats and then you saw it settle
back down again but it's basically been
extraordinarily stable for at least 18
years so
when all you know there's all these
movements that claim all of these people
are abandoning the democratic party
there was the so-called blexit movement
black exit of black people leaving the
democratic party
it's not actually shown in the data the
democratic party registration is very
stable
uh black folks still overwhelmingly
voting for democrats um the claim that
the democratic party is being abandoned
because of supposed wokism
it's not showing up in any data and so
that's what i go by my opinion or
whether i personally know someone that
has left or joined the democratic party
it doesn't really matter what matters is
what does the data show the data doesn't
show that people are abandoning the
democratic party we have a great bonus
show for you today an appeals court
finds florida's new social media law
unconstitutional the supreme court makes
it tougher for inmates to win release
from prison because of bad lawyering
they say they've received and lastly
starbucks is completely exiting russia
joining mcdonald's some mcdonald's and a
bunch of other brands all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
sign up at
joinpacman.com to get instant access